next story actually thought this is one
of the more interesting Star Wars
stories to come out recently Rian
Johnson the director of Star Wars number
whatever asked JJ Abrams to change the
ending to the force awakens what being
asked about it he said yeah the big the
big favor was ascending
I asked if our gear could come with Ray
and a BBA could stay behind with the
resistance originally it was bb-8 who
went with Rey which makes sense for the
story in a way he doesn't really like
you to the rhyming you say can you do me
this solid and switch the droids and JJ
Abrams originally was furious and said
no I have so many more plans with bb-8
and Rey even though I know I'm not
directing the next one I find it very
vital that BBS stays there but it's
important to the continuity the story
it's the Canon it we can't hang so they
snorted cocaine play rock-paper-scissors
150 times until one of the laws oh like
a stalemate every time standing on a
rock in the middle to see paper gotcha
I've done this article interesting
because I don't know I think that is an
interesting choice because now it makes
me curious like well with that what the
hell is Rian Johnson exactly have in
store with it because I know aren't
you're we need to borrow r2d2 well hey
bb-8 what is pose a droid yeah he
doesn't spend a lot of time with Poe no
force awakens potent spend a lot of time
in the force awakens oh he doesn't so I
thought like I'm except I would be cool
to see cuz you know that the
relationship in the beginning of force
awakens he loves that Roy does you can
tell he loves his bb-8 that rose that's
his bro Subrosa
and he any nn9 would want to steal more
of that kind of dynamic between bb-8 and
Poe and r2 and Luke are very closely
linked
to hang out probably and that would be
awkward a little bit but you know
they're both old guidance he's gonna cry
he's gonna cry is gonna cry
that's the sort of films gonna pick up
he takes office his hood he's looked at
our queue and then sheds a tear my mind
would be he takes up his hood and raised
like holy [ __ ] and he starts to walk
towards her and then he walks right past
her and I'm not it doesn't care about
raises to dude like all of right no no
no no mine not and I my or I would be in
much better he would he would look he
take off his hood look at her ray look
at our two and then he would do that
thing you're Tyler it looks like you're
walking up to you do ray and then he
paints a horseshoe starts running away
and she's like were you going any
imports his lightsaber and he starts
running after him and they force pushes
her knocks remember rock kills her and
then we get the less yeah no I know the
loop and rides are today to across the
sea death you know to the nearest town
hijacked the thing I want to show this
army man or chuji to Hitler on that I
just a for Tunisia rapport to detail art
stood we did it we came to times that's
what brainstorming is we move to hey man
just now hey you know what else is
happening in the news today